[Music]
xqc versus stardosh
the winner of group b with the white
pieces versus
the second place player of group a
sarah i'm gonna call my brother because
we have like the same name so
now we're technically related okay you
please all right bishop to c4
and i don't know if he has anything
prepped but his development looks pretty
solid so far but he has been grinding
so much and it's definitely been paying
off in his games
exactly yeah i like to call this uh a
reverse
london everything comes back to the
london but
all right it's always about the london i
like the setup that stardust has gone
for
because the bishop on c4 can be
dangerous pointing at that f7 spot after
e6
you make your spawn structure more solid
and the king safer
the problem is this knight is not very
protected only by queen which means
you're kind of vulnerable
oh wait a minute queen
he gonna go for it now this is no longer
protected though
do i care i mean if he did go
queen after you just bishop b7 right
counteracting right away
yes that would be a good response but
sardosh has to find it so let's see
first of all
i'm gonna go for it
i like it putting him under pressure
okay he
is ready to push his e pawn to e5 and
that would mean that both the knight on
f6
and the rook on a8 would be hanging but
unfortunately for him star deutsche
immediately plays the best response
bishop to b7 another pawn is pinned you
cannot push e5 because that would be
as we know we all know
it yeah the thing with these moves is
like box box called them they're
serotonin moves it looks nice
because he has this one move threat but
now he pretty much just helped black
develop
and now his queen's a little bit pinned
okay he chose to
offer the trade which is also good you
want to trade when you're up material
but i'm not sure that he should allow
them before so
i agree with you that trading overall
it could be beneficial to him but knife
bishop takes eight takes before that
bottom b4 will be
vulnerable and queen to b5 would attack
both the
bishop on b7 and the pawn on b4 so xqc
has a chance to
win the pawn back if he spots that
although queen b5 queen e7 that's still
not over
but it would make sardosh's life more
difficult to develop the knight from b8
at least
it is exactly what you're saying he's a
little bit down so he needs to get an
attack going and this could be the
opportunity for that
and i can fork this oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah move queen here and fork
that
those knight frogs are good ideas but
unfortunately it's not happening
regarding the square and now rook c8
that is
the best move that sardoche has found is
that what i can do here
wow he's gonna trade he's into it is he
oh
he's gonna go for it oh my goodness
kendra we could bring our board back and
show what's happening in this position
with that c5 knight unfortunately for
xqc
this is now pinned through the c5
through the diagonal knight to a6 as yet
another attacking piece
to what's going on on this c5 square
that's the key square here that's the
key piece the c5 knight
is going to fall there's not another
piece that white can bring here to the
defense the d4 knight
unfortunately is unable to guard their
body
on c5 you cannot protect it yeah queen
b5 was the only way he
has the same situation when he pinned
this queen earlier
and now we can't save the piece it's
getting really tough
he doesn't even have any like tactics
try to stack oh
okay is playing knight to d7
to try to bait sardo but he's losing his
rook
played that so quick he didn't even have
to double check he was so confident that
he's taking
the queen and then the rook so both
queens are off of the board but this is
now an
extra rook for sardosh yeah
i mean look at he looks like he's at a
serious chester right now he is so
focused you know when like half your
face
is covered by your hands you're in your
zone he's been killing it
now the rook is gone for the two nights
and what remains on the board is still
unfortunately
very very tough for xqc it's two extra
pieces
and four pawns four best phones for
ourselves
we're going all right okay they did
trade
how to catch up here well okay
and the stalemate chances are looking
better and better what can i say
we gotta push that honey there we go now
it's just the king against the world
but i i don't think i don't know if his
dreams are gonna come true
let's see if it's gonna be stalemate or
checkmate we are just a few moves away
from
seeing the reality if quinter
don't lose it well he shouldn't bring
the queen that close he brings the king
in and now it's checkmate on the person
first game no mercy at all wow
so yeah excuse you really threw
everything he had for that stalemate but
sardoche
played very clean that was a killer game
saradosh won the first game meaning that
xqc is in a must
win situation he has to win if he
doesn't win
eliminated the london system android's
already getting excited let's see the gm
he car preparation
this is the game i've been looking
forward to man because
i don't play a single other opening as
white except the london system so when i
see it
i get really excited because it's you
know the one thing i've studied a lot
all right so far so good knight to c6 is
the move that he car was showing to xqc
with the setup being e6 and bishop to d6
that's the issue this f4 push whether it
was the best or not it has prevented
the gm recovery preparation where they
mainly were focusing on positions with
the trade
of bishops now the trade of the bishop
for the e5 knight how do you see the
opening of the f-file in this system
i i think i mean this is okay i i think
these pawns are pretty strong
and that now we have the bishop pair
sometimes i get really annoyed when you
know they copy you
and then they come do the same thing and
get their own pawns and then even push a
5-2
but i don't know if xqc is going to come
for the center
yeah so the hard thing here and i was
going to ask you what do you think the
best plan for xqc to develop
is because his pieces are all pretty
passive and all bunched up together and
retreated already
it's tough you're right with the knight
on d7 the way of the bishop
oh f6 though i think i was gonna say
i think you need to try to to explode
that central structure of white
f6 is the way to go but bishop h4 by
sardos immediately to pin the pawn
he is so fast no this is yeah this is
great because
his pieces could not develop anywhere he
has to break through somewhere but
sardosa is playing these
fantastic moves so fast pushing the pawn
to g5
would be too committal he should
definitely not weaken his kingdom
g5
[Music]
okay i mean um maybe it can still turn
out well but i feel like this is
too committal yeah now just xqc's
king is almost naked and afraid look at
all these holes
yeah so now it's up to sardosh maybe
he's gonna see this idea try to prevent
it and
play something safe like we're treating
his bishop or
even more aggressive i wonder i guess he
doesn't have any sac idea like queen h5
take the bishop give some checks and
clean up his pawns
there's a lot of ideas for white wait a
second he won the first game so if he
finds a way in which he can force a
perpetual
you would be claiming the match so it's
it makes a lot of sense for him to look
for queen h5 queen g6 and try to give
perpetual yeah
actually i think this is a perpetual
because
king f8 queen check and here then we
have
a mate threat so so there actually is a
force
well if they take the bishop though so
queen h5 is an interesting name
i think you have just solved the match
if he spots queen to
h5 which either is
with a really strong attack for white or
if the bishop is accepted
it's a perpetual check for white that's
all that sardosh needs
the next stage to the semi-finals he
plays instead which is
which is very ambitious but it may not
be oh my god it's now the advantages
in black side i think maybe the plan is
f5
but the eval bar took a big drop i think
he has stubbed into
the sacrifice i was trying to make
knight takes e5
you've been oh oh the knight one not
even the f5
okay let's play it out live so that when
d takes
the other knight takes and now the queen
and the bishop are hanging
and if you drop the queen back to e2 to
guard the d3 bishop then the h4 bishop
is taken so you cannot guard both
bishops
wow wow okay i don't want to miss it
let's see
if he's gonna if xqc is gonna find it
yeah f5 was a little bit of a safer move
still blocking the attack but that was a
really complicated
tactic there let's go board back and
show what's happening because stardust
had to realize that the bishop was gonna
be lost so he places a knight on f3 and
then takes on h4
if we just roll back one move i was
really worried again about that queen
appearing near the king so instead of
knight takes h4 which happened instantly
i thought sardosh could have gone for
your idea with the perpetual queen to g6
again and that's better on h7
so that that square is guarded but these
are
tiny details that are very difficult to
spot
when you're in the midst of the game and
it's such a complex messy position
knight takes h4 makes sense too to try
to attack the king let's see
if xqc will bring more pieces to the
king side you need to get your
rook and queen involved rook to g8 for
instance would be very logical
and all that sardoche has is a pawn to
compensate for it not much
especially considering that it's not a
past pawn
they're stacked as we say not doubled
exactly stacked pawns oh and now
g4 offering the pawn i don't know if
stardust miscalculated it that there are
two pieces of black attacking that
square
yes he takes the pawn wow
oh he was planning to win it back but i
mean black can just defend his pawn here
he might have miscalculated that now
there's h5
push wow the pawn and the rook on g3
is stuck so it's not only that he lost
the player you can't go anywhere
the phone on its own wouldn't be that
much of a disaster but the fact that you
cannot move your
rook ever how will he activate the g3
rook
oh no i was gonna say just has to watch
out for this night check
he's been preparing but we all right
oh okay so excuse he did step into the
night fork but it's
not the end of the world if if he will
take one of
the minor pieces for it so he can either
take on g6 or move the king and then
take back on f8
yeah there's there's a few i think even
after
i think he has already made his decision
before we could have listened and he
does take on g6 but now he has to be
careful with those paws the h5 pawn is
hanging and if he loses that pawn the g4
pawn two will fall
yeah he only has one way to defend his
pawn bishop e8 he
right now even though he just lost
exchange he's still doing much better
because he has this past pawn here
but he can't drop these pawns yes he's
got two minor pieces for the rook but he
has to guard the pawns and you're right
andra it's not so easy to find
bishop e8 or or something tricky with
the knight jumps if
if he gets over to to f5 but that's way
too dank knight he's seven to then go
knight
oh he's dropping them these were the key
the key to success oh no oh
and now it's back in white's favor the
g3 rook was completely dead and now it's
back in the game after the g4 pawn
he's breaking free from the chains of
this pawn and
taking two pawns almost and there goes
another one
oh man oh no and the issue with the king
to h6 is that
after rook age wow or bishop g4 there
will be checkmate patterns too now
yeah we got the rook roller here holding
back the king we just have to take this
pawn
wow what a turn of events
excuse me with the piece of but he did
not
see that night for coming rook fade
would have been a logical move if it
wasn't for the tactical pattern
and now this should be mating too
brook takes g4 king goes back to h6 and
this
cover check mate
and if king to f5 and now it's just made
in one
oh my goodness yeah
[Music]
man the rage and the happiness he wins
his quarterfinals 2-0 against
sqc moves on to the semi-finals
well it was very very stressful because
i knew xqc was really good in open
position
and so otherwise so i could get punished
if i go for tactics
so well i i tried to close it up a bit
uh i knew he had the preparation for my
london system by kyro
just before the stream but sadly i had
my coach telling me exactly
how to actually contact this so i'm
really sorry but my coach won on this
one
is that a shout out to blitzstream kevin
vordey
i must admit i would have never found it
by myself
uh that was kevin kevin body yeah sorry
sorry i'm really sorry but the game was
really intense i put myself in a so hard
situation
in the white game and you you did so
well with your pawns i was
in so big trouble and well i i gave up
my
my bishop and went like okay maybe my
maybe my knight we
will do the job and he did at the end so
i'm proud that well that was
a bit lucky yeah
the bishop was stuck on the left side of
the map and uh
[Laughter]
i'm just kidding yeah i thought uh the
bishop and the queen were
uh were like stack uh upper left but
the only thing is that uh at mid there's
like a four tread i could have done that
i didn't see
and the computer kept saying it wrong
wrong
like he didn't want me to do it but i i
i didn't see it again get aggressive
are you talking about the night fork or
in the very
first game yeah the night sacrifice to
knight take night
the two of you have been on a huge grind
for the whole event as you said
xqc uh you started basically pogchamps
we we can thank
thank to you and the collaboration with
you and hikaru that
the entire chess boom started and the
the series the pogchamps series grew out
of that collaboration
and now you are here for your third poke
gyms unfortunately will need to say
goodbye to you but will we see you be
back for [__] chance four
yeah yeah it'll be good it'll be good
when i come back i'll be uh stronger
than ever and i'll uh i'll take the
crown then
we'll be awesome to get to every match
yep okay
thank you guys
[Music]
you